when the crisis struck in February it
was a health crisis first after some
initial attempts by member states to
respond individually Europe quickly
pulled itself together and tackled this
unprecedented challenge Europe is on
track to work its way out of this crisis
but it's already apparent that the whole
world will reach a crossroads when the
health aspect and the economic aspects
come together our economies will only
pick up full speed and indeed our lives
will only go back to normal when we have
an effective and safe vaccine against
this virus today we are proposing our
European vaccine strategy at its core
joint action at EU level will allow all
Member States to increase the likelihood
of finding an effective vaccine and to
secure the necessary volumes for our
citizens at a good price doing so we
also avoid harmful competition amongst
each other and we deliver tangible
European solidarity we have been working
closely since many weeks with member
states and with pharmaceutical companies
in order to set up this joint approach
last Friday health ministers agreed to
work together in this way we will now
act very quickly because in overcoming
this pandemic every day matters at the
same time the European Commission is
supporting the idea of an Universal and
affordable access to vaccines especially
for the most vulnerable countries who
struggle to secure enough vaccine for
their people on the global market the
European Union already coordinated a
global pledging to raise close to 10
billion euro but much more is needed and
that's why we will continue to mobilize
funding and political commitment from
across the globe we are working towards
global summit on the 27th of June we
will explore with
our international partners whether a
significant number of countries would
agree to pool resources for jointly
reserving future vaccines from companies
while at the same time making advance
reservations for low and middle income
countries the high-income countries
would then act as an inclusive
international buyers group they would
thus accelerate the development of safe
and effective vaccines and help maximize
access to them across the world for all
who need it when it comes to fighting a
global pandemic there is no place for me
first
Europe is not an island our economies
are tightly connected not only amongst
themselves but also with the rest of the
world through global trade travel and
cooperation only when the economies of
our trading partners will recover
Europe's economies will thrive again and
only when the world will be safe from
the coronavirus European citizens will
be safe as well